Hey there, smartless listeners, Conan O'Brien here. Wanted to let you know I recently had your very own Jason Bateman on my podcast, Conan O'Brien Needs a Friend, who talked about Jason's roots as a child star, his breakout role on Arrest Development, and of course his fellow smartless co-host, Sean and Will. Here's a little taste of what we got up to. You know, the question is, are you Conan O'Brien's friend if you aren't invited to his Christmas party? And you know, there's so many hundreds of Conan O'Brien's friend if you aren't invited to his Christmas party? And you know, there's so many hundreds
and hundreds of people. We've straightened this out. No, thousands are invited to the Christmas party. I invite thousands and about 50 come. Listen, we're gonna just, cause this has been a thing and then I went on SmartList recently, you know, about you coming to the Christmas party
and it was a thing for a while. You claim you weren't invited. I was shocked that there was the Christmas party. And it was a thing for a while. You claim you weren't invited. I was shocked that there was a Christmas party. That the Christmas party had been going on for years. But you were, I think you were shocked that Christmas was celebrated. Because you're such a cringe. That Christmas had something to do
with your Lord and Savior, Jesus Christ. I was like. Well, listen, the point is you, you know, let's talk about smart lists. It's a juggernaut. You guys are. It's a pretty hard pivot. It's a real, I mean, I was a four wheel slide. Can I say something?
Right? I just broke my hip pivoting. But no, the point I'm trying to make is of you three guys, you got Will Arnett, you got Sean, is it Hayes? Yeah, I think it's H-A-Z-E. Okay. And then you're Jason.
Bateman. Bateman. Okay, there's the three of you, and you're the one that I have trouble getting a beat on. I gotta say, you're the one, you're squirrely. You're squirrely, Bateman. I've always had a problem getting a beat on. I gotta say, you're the one, you're squirrely. You're squirrely, Bateman. I've always had a problem getting a beat on you. A huge fan of yours. I adore you, but I can't get a beat on the guy.
I can't. Because you can sense that I'm not sure why I'm there. And I don't really, I'm not really sure if I, I don't get it. I don't understand why people listen to it. I get that Will and Sean are appealing fellas. That's why they're two of my best friends. And we're not doing anything more than just the drivel
that happens when we're in a car together or at a dinner. I just don't think that that's monetizable. That you should ask for people's attention to listen to that. That you can monetizable. That you should ask for people's attention to listen to that. That you can monetize. I agree with it about your podcast. I agree, because I've checked it out. And I'm like, I can't believe that this is something,
I mean, this, what we're doing here. You've got a full, you've got an array of talent here. And you've probably done some- Hold on a second, let me put my glasses on. She's really disagree with that. You've done some- Hold on a second, let me put my glasses on. Jesus, really? Even we disagree with that. You've done some prep, right? I can see questions there.
No, no, no, this is your medical history. Oh. This is your medical history. You've got a handsome studio, you've got cameras around. This is very professional. Yeah, also- We're on a Zoom. Also, can I just point out,
I've been interviewing people around the clock since 1993. I'm a seasoned professional on what Muhammad Ali was to boxing I am to interviewing. We can cut all this off. You need lifts. Yeah. Yeah. But you guys with this, you know, R&N.
But in, yes, but at least Will, at least Will has just sharp dagger humor. He's got a darkness that's fun to follow. A voice that's not bad to listen to. No, I buy whatever truck he's selling. Right? Yeah. I mean, as long as it's professional grade.
He's got an opinion and he'll let you know it. Sean P. Hayes is sure is just pure sunshine and is curious and is warm. And I'm trying to find the lane that I'm supposed to be in which is the area in between those two which I guess is just sort of listening and asking questions that I think the normal guy wants to know. You know?
And so I feel I'm easily replaceable. Yes, yes, I was gonna say the same thing. I was gonna say, I'm glad you said it. I beat you. No, no, no, I think you could come, you could go, you know, whatever. Which is kind of what I do and whatever the hell I do on camera too.
I'm trying to just kind of be us. To hear the rest of the episode, as well as other great conversations I've had with folks like Amy Poehler, Adam Scott, Ben Stiller, and more, check out Conan O'Brien Needs a Friend, wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.